Hi, Greg
Hi, GDC attendees
You're looking great today.
So I'm here with Ben from the
Google Play Game Services Team
and we're going to be
playing a multiplayer game
of Beach Buggy Racing
But we only have one controller
and a whole bunch of Android phones
So Ben, how we're going
to make this work?
So fortunately, the developer
of "Beach Buggy Racing" factory unite
has implemented something called
a nearby connections API
That allows us to connect our
Android devices to the Android TV
and use them as controllers
And it's broadcasting a signal
behind the scenes saying,
"Hey, all the phones nearby,
I'm available to connect"
And now, the race begins!
- Go, go, go!
- I press power!
So I've noticed now
that we've started playing...
your phone has changed!
What's going on here?
As my hands tilt back and forth
you can tell that
an accelerometer now
is being used to drive
But more importantly, there's a couple
of really neat things that are going on...
that I can do now
with an Android device as a controller
that are difficult to do
with a standard controller
And so the first thing is there's these
extra annotations on the screen here
like in the upper right-hand corner
you can see I have
this Nitrous booster icon
which I can press.
Then on the left-hand side,
I've got my special powers
We've got some brake
pads down at the bottom.
So I can take these
corners a little better
And of course, there's some animated dials
in the middle
indicating how fast I'm going
- Let's play again!
- All right
We're going to do a rematch here.
Greg, we're going to let you take over.
- Bye, Masconi!
- Ciao!